[Musica]
se c'è una parola che più di altre viene
utilizzata spesso per identificare e
caratterizzare persone che sono dal
punto di vista della salute precarie è
una parola che vegetale che usiamo
sempre per dire magari una persona che
non sta bene no quasi un vegetale come
per dire che quasi vive appena
sopravvive in realtà come diceva prima
antonio le piante sono essere
estremamente intelligenti ed una cosa
che non stiamo scoprendo oggi il primo
che intuì questa cosa si chiamava
charles darwin che tutti quanti
conosciamo per la teoria
dell'evoluzionismo
ma in realtà nessuno sa che lui scrisse
un libro questo il potere di movimento
delle piante circa 150 anni fa e
nell'ultima pagina di questo libro
accennò a un intelligenza delle piante
posizionato proprio nella parte apicale
della radice nella parte terminale che
la parte più giovane e che quella che è
capace di individuare nel terreno
sostanze nutritive acqua minerali tutto
quello che serve la pianta per poter
vivere ma non poteva dire che le piante
erano intelligenti perché avrebbero
l'avrebbero sicuramente chiuso in
manicomio
che cos'è che frena ha frenato e
continuerà sempre a fare ma a frenare
l'evoluzione dell'uomo il pregiudizio
noi siamo ancora oggi convinti e la
nostra concezione del mondo vegetale
ferma al 1509 nonostante viviamo nel
siamo convinti come charles debbo verso
questo filosofo francese che nel 1509
disegno questa piramide dei viventi
mettendo in cima all uomo considerato
intelligente nel gradino più basso
gli animali considerati senzienti se ha
un cane li diamo un calcio sicuramente
reagisce a bahia
poi le piante nel gradino un po più
basso considerate viventi e infine le
rocce appena esistenti e tutt'oggi la
nostra concezione del mondo vegetale
questa qui il pregiudizio a che fare con
le scelte i ragionamenti che facciamo
ogni giorno perché noi non vediamo con i
nostri occhi noi vediamo che le nostre
idee
se vedessimo con gli occhi non
litigheremo tutti i giorni andremo
d'accordo
il problema è che ognuno parte dal suo
punto di vista
e spesso non è identico a quello degli
altri e allora il pregiudizio spesso ci
impedisce di vedere quello che invece
oggi gli scienziati quelli attuali
levando dagli occhi questa lente del
pregiudizio hanno cominciato a studiare
a capire né riprendendo ovviamente le
ricerche dei b che abbiamo visto prima
che le piante sono esseri estremamente
intelligenti sono molto più intelligenti
di noi e hanno molte più risorse di noi
spesso andremo a vedere come queste
piante ci possono rendere utili la vita
o come possano migliorare nel caso della
mia del mio intervento il modo di fare
impresa
sicuramente c'è un dato da tenere in
considerazione perché oggi sfateremo un
po di miti noi esseri umani assieme gli
animali siamo una minoranza schiacciante
sul pianeta terra la maggior parte della
biomassa presente sul pianeta è formato
da piante tra l'ottanta il 99,7 per
cento
praticamente il restante sono tracce
eppure noi ci consideriamo in cima a
questa piramide ci consideriamo i
padroni del pianeta perché nonostante
viviamo in un contesto assolutamente
predominante dal punto di vista delle
piante ci consideriamo abbiamo quest'app
live club bling bling blindness
praticamente questa cecità nei confronti
delle piante perché l'uomo ha sempre
vissuto nel corso verso insistenza in un
ambiente dove le piante erano lo sfondo
della sua vita e quindi il cervello che
ovviamente non puoi lavorare tantissime
informazioni deve selezionarle
ovviamente dava per scontato che ci
fossero questi esseri viventi intorno a
sé e quindi eliminava in qualche modo
questo elemento concentrandosi sugli
animali da cacciare su quello che
serviva per vivere e per sopravvivere
soprattutto all'epoca è un po come oggi
le città
il case ormai non ci facciamo più caso
proprio perché ci viviamo immersi
eppure alle piante sulla terra la sanno
molto più lunga di noi perché vivono da
molto più tempo di noi sul pianeta 800
milioni di anni fa
le prime per piante comparvero
nell'acqua le alghe poi cominciarono a
spiaggiarsi sulle rive della terra
cominciarono a generare humus da questo
humus nacquero le prime piante terrestri
con delle radici è così l'unico dato che
abbiamo oggi che ci da questo
questa questo tempo che sono 425 milioni
di anni
sono gli unici fossili che abbiamo
trovato che sono fossili appunto di
muschi che sono piante che per primi
colonizzano un territorio e se me li
cani invece l'uomo arriva dopo
moltissimo tempo 5 milioni e mezzo 35
milioni e mezzo e due milioni di anni
non arriva
ma arrivano degli esseri che somigliano
all'uomo ma che sono più animali che
uomini
dopodichè per attendere un homo sapiens
dobbiamo arrivare a 195 mila anni fa
mentre abbiamo cominciato a fare danni
soltanto da 70 mila anni quindi diciamo
quando abbiamo cominciato a conquistare
il pianeta e colonizzarlo in qualche
modo e in effetti il nostro modo di
ragionare va in quella direzione
nella direzione l'antropocentrismo se
tutto quello che ci circonda non
assomiglia al nostro modo di essere di
ragionare noi non comprendiamo quello
che abbiamo intorno
e se non le assomiglia non lo facciamo
assomigliare in qualche modo
ecco perché magari cerchiamo di far sì
che animali e piante ragionino
assomiglino si comportino un po come noi
esseri umani e gli scienziati che adesso
stanno studiando le piante hanno capito
che le piante possono servirci per fare
per migliorare la nostra vita la maggior
parte di loro le sta utilizzando per
capire come migliorare le strutture
architettoniche come vivere in posti
dove è difficile magari sopravvivere per
carenza di acqua o per condizioni
ambientali difficili come creare dei
plan toy de per andare su marte più
tardi avremo un intervento sul tema cioè
stiamo sempre cercando di capire come
rubare delle informazioni per il milione
della vostra la nostra vita molto meno
sono accettati che ho comunque le
persone che si stanno interessando di
che cosa le piante possono insegnarci
le piante non ci insegneranno mai nulla
perché non parlano non si muovono no non
sono loro a venire da noi se non siamo
noi capaci di metterci in ascolto
se non abbiamo la sensibilità di
comprendere che hanno un linguaggio
silenzioso particolare nei confronti del
quale noi siamo ovviamente sprovvisti
degli strumenti spesso per comprende
e invece scopriremo osservandole con
molto milta che possono insegnarci tante
cose e in particolare innanzitutto le
piante sono esseri immobili nel senso
che non si spostano per che le piante si
spostano anche ma lo fanno molto
lentamente
tutto quello che si muove lentamente per
noi è immobile perché non lo vediamo in
tempo reale
e allora la prima cosa che ci insegnano
e che a dispetto degli esseri umani o si
adattano a quello che accade nel
territorio oppure muoiono mentre noi
esseri umani di fronte ai problemi
fuggiamo abbiamo le gambe le piante
devono fare di più se stessa per gli
orazi taxi e pare resilienza cioè
capacità di resistere agli urti della
vita primo grande insegnamento che ci
danno e quindi la bugia non è che in
natura vince il più forte ci hanno
sempre raccontato perché vi segnava in
porro modello economico arrogante e
ovviamente conquistatore che in natura
vince il più forte no di natura vince il
più adatto che non è necessario che sia
neanche il pin telligent è quello che
riesce nelle condizioni ambientali in
cui si trova e vive a superare le
difficoltà a continuare a vivere primo
insegnamento
quindi quando sento gli imprenditori che
dicono non ho le strade non ho il comune
che mi supportano no l'aiuto economico
no no no no no no mi viene da ridere
perché non esiste l'ambiente ideale non
esiste il paradiso su questa terra
quando vedo giovani che emigrano e se ne
vanno per trovare l'eden del dorato
trova viene da ridere perché esistono le
condizioni possibili all'interno di un
territorio che ovviamente alle sue i
suoi punti di forza e punti di debolezza
l'imprenditore quello capace di
accentuare i punti di forza e ridurre
quelli di debolezza altro insegnamento
il secondo che se ci mettiamo ad
osservare tutti quegli scienziati
passano la vita a osservare un singolo
fenomeno se non osserviamo abbastanza
lunga la nostra società frenetica in cui
non abbiamo il tempo soffermarci sul
nulla hanno scopriremo nulla perché il
novecento è stato un epoca di grandi
scoperte l'ottocento è il 2000 non è non
è così non è all'altezza in tutti i
campi perché non abbiamo più la capacità
di soffermarci e di osservare con
attenzione senza pregiudizi come abbiamo
prima e senza fretta e presunzione la
stessa cosa fanno gli imprenditori che
non osservano i loro clienti
e difficilissimo trovare quanti
imprenditori riescono a guardare come
interagisce il loro cliente con il
prodotto e servizio che hanno creato
quasi nessuno tutti danno per scontato
che siccome l'ho ideato io che sono più
intelligente lo adopereranno come voglio
io
non è così osservate i vostri clienti vi
renderete conto che il vostro prodotto
non era quello che avevate immaginato
all'inizio terzo elemento nel momento in
cui guardiamo caos o innanzitutto ci
mettiamo da un punto di osservazione che
è il nostro io quando faccio le
esperienze sensoriali natura e mi
soffermo di fronte delle forme come
quella che state vedendo non ed è la
stessa forma qualcuno potrebbe vedere
una forma diversa perché dipende da dove
mi metto a guardare
quell'albero con la forma se la guarda
da questo lato dall'altro lato potrebbe
averne un'altra quindi il primo
insegnamento che ci dalla natura che è
la vita un punto di vista è per andare
d'accordo mi devo mettere dal punto di
osservazione dell'altro
il secondo insegnamento e che se mi
metto troppo vicino non vedo nulla per
risolvere i problemi non devo esserci
immerso fino al collo mi devo
allontanare dal problema lo devo
guardare da lontano e come per magia mi
apparirà una soluzione perché solo
osservando dall'alto ed essendo
distaccati emotivamente dai problemi
riusciremo a trovare una con bando della
matassa
non è un caso se qualcuno che è disposto
a pagare 5mila euro per prendere un
caffè con questa signorina quindi i
servizi ai prodotti che ne forniamo non
sono oggettivi sono soggettivi il valore
che noi diamo il prodotto il servizio
non è una questione pezzo quando sento
dire non siamo competitivi perché siamo
troppo carino dipende dal servizio che
dai
c'è chi è disposto a pagare 5mila euro
per prendere un caffè
altra cosa che ci insegnano le piante le
piante hanno un centro si chiama durame
e là tra le del tronco ed è quella che
mantiene la struttura dell'albero se non
ci fosse questa parte rigida che in
qualche modo rappresenta il nostro
passato e che la parte morta dell'app
dove la linfa non scorre più ma per
mantenere l'albero stabile durante i
temporali le tempeste le oscillazioni
ecco se abbiamo costruito un passato
solido allora potremmo continuare ad
allargarci ma soprattutto sappiamo qual
è il nostro core business quale problema
risolviamo col nostro prodotto servizio
perché quello che fa la differenza in un
mercato altro insegnamento straordinario
le piante ci insegnano che si possano
tirare fuori le risorse nascoste ogni
pianta a delle gemme che si chiamano
dormienti potrebbero non entrare mai in
funzione nella vita di un albero quando
entra in funzione quando l'albero
subisce un trauma
quanti di voi conoscono persone che sono
rimasti traumatizzati da incidenti
stradali o da situazioni gravi nella
vita
io penso ad alex zanardi penso a
tantissimi personaggi pistorius che poi
cos'hanno fatto e si sono rassegnati no
hanno tirato fuori leggerne dormienti
hanno tirato fuori delle risorse i
problemi sono opportunità ben vengano
abbiamo bisogno ogni giorno di problemi
invece noi di fronte problemi ci
lamentiamo a c'è un problema il problema
opportunità
altra cosa le piante ci insegnano ad
avere fiducia quando devono impollinare
si devono affidare al vento all'acqua
agli animali non possono fare da soli e
nessuno di noi può fare niente da solo
se non si affida all'ambiente nel quale
vive e quindi bisogna fare questa di
fiducia coltivarla non chiudersi
condividere la conoscenza noi calabresi
in particolare non racconto la mia idea
se non me la fregano
ma poi rimane nel cassetto non la fai
netto negli altri altra cosa creare
relazioni non le vediamo le radici
perché sono sottoterra ma una bosco
insieme di alberi è un superorganismo
non ragiona come un singolo individuo
ragiona come un sistema si scambiano
informazioni di pericolo
ad esempio attraverso le radici le
piante attraverso dei segnali elettrici
le piante collaborano le piante che
hanno meno acqua che hanno più acqua la
passano quelli che ne hanno di meno gli
alberi più gracili vengono aiutati dagli
alberi più forti è una rete internet
come una rete internet alla nostra
società
ce l'ha dimostrato facebook ci ha fatto
vedere in maniera plateale che tutti noi
siamo collegati
sicuramente avrete sentito parlare della
teoria dei sei gradi di separazione
ognuno di noi al massimo 6 passaggio o
collegarsi con qualsiasi altro individuo
esistente sul pianeta perché il mondo e
rotonde gira spesso ce lo dimentichiamo
siamo un unico un'unica famiglia e
invece ci comportiamo come delle isole
non so che farmene le eccellenze di un
territorio che poi non comunicano tra di
loro anche perché per competere in un
mercato globale
oggi mettiamo insieme oppure non andiamo
da nessuna parte poi le piante sono un
anno una struttura aree non hanno
un'organizzazione verticistica perché le
organizzazioni degli esseri umani non
funzionano perché hanno un cervello
basta danneggiare quello e tutto il
resto non va ma soprattutto perché dalla
cima dal vertice fino all'ultimo che
deve seguire il compito
i passaggi sono così tanti che ci sono
margini di errore o di ritardo di genere
enormi invece le piante come sapete se
gli tagliate un ramon e cresce un altro
anno una intelligenza di poeta
orizzontale e ci dimostrano che queste
sono organizzazioni molto più efficienti
sviluppare troppi le piante devono
sviluppare reazioni agli ambienti a
quello che accade le piante carnivore
non sono carnivoro perché sono cattive
vivono in terreni poveri di azoto hanno
bisogno di come dire alimentarsi di
insetti che sono ricchi di azoto per
sopperire alla carenza che c'è del
terreno ma tutte le danno dei troppi smi
si adeguano alle condizioni ambientali
troppa luce troppa umidità eccetera
eccetera e reagiscono la stessa cosa
devono fare le imprese questi sono i
troppi smi che noi dovremmo ideare per
superare queste difficoltà nel
territorio c'è burocrazia istituzioni
assenti criminalità qualsiasi cosa e con
le imprese reti che questa realtà questa
idea
più che altro che non esiste niente di
strutturato ma questo è a questo
concetto questo aggettivo che sapeva
differenziare il modo di fare impresa
dieci anni fa ho immaginato un modo
diverso e ho trovato tante realtà del
territorio una oggi sarà qui a te
stefano caccavari che agiscono con
questa mentalità in maniera
assolutamente differente
il penultimo elemento è che bisogna
avere una visione sistemica
non possiamo immaginare di agire
isolatamente quando noi agiamo abbiamo
delle conseguenze creiamo delle
conseguenze su chi ci sta intorno
quindi non possiamo prescindere da chi
ci circonda e soprattutto l'impresa un
sistema aperto non può funzionare in
maniera isolata rispetto agli altri come
una cellula le cellule devono interagire
c'è sempre una comunicazione tra
l'interno
infine lasciare andare quando in autunno
cadono le foglie non muoiono non esiste
la morte perché la natura tutto si
trasforma niente si distrugge
quando le foglie cadono a terra servono
a creare un sconci ma se non c'è morte
non può esserci vita e quindi la morte
di qualcosa è sempre la vita di
qualcos'altro non esiste in natura
niente la stessa cosa nelle imprese
quanti marchi sono morti noi non
esistono più
però vedo sempre imprenditori attaccati
ai loro beni agli immobili alle
strutture ai marchi alle idee che poi
passano la maggior parte in sofferenze
che abbiamo nella vita nascono
dall'attaccamento che abbiamo nei
confronti di persone cose idee ma non ci
appartengono noi siamo altro come ne
abbiamo avuta ieri un'idea ce l'avremo
domani sono chiesti tico di idea pur di
non averne più e infine l'unica vera
insegnamento che ci danno gli alberi che
l'esatto opposto di esseri umani che
stravolgiamo tutto quello che ci
circonda pur di non cambiare in sé
stessi e che ho imparato sulla mia pelle
in questi ultimi dieci anni e che
bisogna avere la capacità di fare un
grande lavoro su se stessi perché se si
vuole cambiare il territorio bisogna
iniziare a cambiare se stessi e come per
magia vi renderete conto e goor tutto
quello che vi circonda comincerà a
cambiare grazie
[Applauso]